oblivion now with no Elder Scrolls
that's right oblivion the movie is not
related to the Elder Scrolls oblivion
game so if any of you out there were
wondering why Tom Cruise is hunting down
Daedric gods in a post-apocalyptic
futuristic wasteland of Earth and you
know not related oblivion so the story
of oblivion was there was a big war
between aliens and human beings and we
wiped out the earth well in the war
though that's the goal for us and how
all the humans have migrated to the moon
Titan and now Tom Cruise and this one
chick or here the cleanup crew they
watch over the drones they fix the
drones when they get broken Tom Cruise
does a really good job in the movie The
Dude's established as a good actor he's
nuts
yeah most really good artists are you
can tell Tom Cruise in this check
they're not supposed to ask questions
they're just supposed to do their job
but Tom Cruise you know he has hopes and
dreams and questions and he goes off to
his little happy place
so you're lying to your chick so you can
escape and go away and be by yourself
and your own thoughts it's good to know
that a monumental thing like the
apocalypse will not change marriage know
what I personally think hurt this movie
the most is the trailer the movies built
on this intrigue like what's going on
you know something's not quite right in
the movie but that's in the movie
innately you have this question you have
the same question Tom Cruise has where
you're like I don't know what it is but
something doesn't quite fit and the
trailer I feel shows a bit too much it
was just a trailer that was like Oh Tom
Cruise and post-apocalypse and come see
because you're kind of intrigued now
that would have been great you would
have been lost in this movie a little
longer if they'd gone that route but the
payoff would have been a lot better
instead the trailer kind of lets you
know a bit more than you should and
that's stupid which brings us to the
supporting cast in this movie the
supporting cast ultimately there's this
group of people they're pretty much like
Denis Leary's guys and demolition man
and that whole thing isn't as relevant
as the movie wants you to believe it is
a couple of little alterations in the
script and that entire thing all those
people didn't even have to be in the
movie in the story they are there to
pretty much heard Tom Cruise from point
A to point 900 C little alteration Tom
Cruise could have gone to point B and
then C without them Morgan Freeman's in
the movie which is one of the things
that's kind of ruined and spoiled
because of the trailer but the trailer
has to show you that because it's Morgan
Freeman if they got Joe Blow nobody then
they wouldn't have shown you that I
would have rather they gotten Joe Blow
nobody my thing with oblivion it looks
cool it's really intriguing you're on
this journey with Tom Cruise you want to
find things out with them but then you
have these other elements that bog the
movie down
there are times where you're like I'm
interested to see what happens next but
I am bored it's like for everything good
in oblivion there is something bad
that's counterbalancing it and in the
end although I did walk out of oblivion
liking it as a whole I'm not gonna be
like this is the movie you need to see
now I'm gonna make a slight alteration
to one of my ratings I don't like doing
that I feel like it's a cop-out so I
will say oblivion is a good time no
alcohol required at matinee price total
cop-out I know I get you so oblivion
have you seen it yet are you looking
forward to seeing it what do you think
of it whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more